So here's one last helpful loop, the for in loop.
For in loops let us easily iterate through arrays or objects.
The syntax looks like this.
The same keyword for.
We have some kind of iterator, which we can give any name that we want.
Then we have the keyword in, and then an object or
array that we want to iterate through.
For each of the items in some object, we want to do something.
Just like before, we put the conditions for our for loop inside parentheses and
the statements we want to execute inside curly braces.
It's important to note here that this item,
this iterator in this list is actually the index of the item in the object,
not the value held at the index in the object.
So let's take a look at an example.
We have an array called countries,
which has the top four teams of the 2014 World Cup.
We have a for in loop here, which is going to iterate for
each country in the countries array, we want to log that country.
Hey, James.
Do you see anything wrong with this code?
>> It's just going to print out, zero through three and
not the actual country name.
>> Why is that?
>> Because country is an iterator in countries.
It's not the actual value of country.
>> That's right, so let's make a change.
Instead we should have console.log countries of the index country.
Let's see if this is correct.
So, here's our for in loop in one line of code.
By using Shift + Enter, we can actually put this in a much nicer format.
So we see, for (country in countries) ; and
I'm pressing Enter.
We see Germany, Argentina, Brazil, and The Netherlands.
>> You should already have a work object with all of your work experiences.
I want you to write a for-in loop that iterates over all the jobs in
your work object and appends them in a new HTMLworkStart element.
I want you to also format each job's employer with HTMLworkEmployer in
each job title with HTMLworkTitle and append all of that to the page.
Click this box when you're done.